from lazy Adam Sandler comes yet another
lazy part let's sorted out comedy that
America will inexplicably pay to see
grown-ups join an all-star cast of
comedic actors and Rob Schneider as they
dish out more the mindless crap
audiences love he jokes ah for the jokes
for jokes more B jokes and more fart
jokes prepared and give up your own
hard-earned money to pay for these rich
actors to go on vacation with their
families seriously
this will be cost eighty billion dollars
and they shot it at a lake
it's lowest-common-denominator comedy at
its laziest substituting plot with and
character with guys getting hit in the
face guys getting hit in the foot
guys getting hit in the deck and even
more fart jokes journey along with the
celebrity man babies as they attempt to
become grown-ups Lenny's got Adam
Sandler problems he's too rich and his
wife is too high
Kurt is african-american but he can't
play basketball
Higgs will have sex with anything just
like David Spade rob has two hot
daughters that his friends creepily want
a bag and fat Kevin James is fat you
wonder what I fantasize about yet candy
bars did we mention he's totally fat 17
burgers and 17 fries okay
and that'll be just for me what are you
guys having haha so get ready for
another lazy Adam Sandler movie full of
the things you've come to expect product
placement
Adam Sandler's friends and joke so
devoid of humor creativity or effort I
always wanted to represent you you're
the third Olsen 20 you won't know when
to laugh but don't worry they will haha
alright we got okay it's really not
funny
still not funny
Jesus it's really not fun story Shiba
Domino's yeah but uh boo boo boo not
Chris Farley also not Chris Farley every
movie hates chris plots boobs Adam
Sandler's friend whoever that cross-eye
dude is and a carrot grown-ups
you know if you see grownups too you're
only encouraging him I wasted no thanks
for watching be sure to subscribe it's
over 9000
I've fallen and I can't get up
I am the
knocks it easy being cheesy go ahead
make my day